have you ever considered how your choice  of database could ease development and  help accelerate your time to market  Google Cloud spanner the horizontally  scalable relational database provides  all the familiarity of relational  databases such as transactions across  rows and forced data types schema and  complex queries meaning no time lost  learning new languages or paradigms and  unlike traditional relational databases  cloud spanner grows with the needs of  your app so you can have confidence in  the knowledge that you'll never have to  reap lat form for scale cloud spanner  not only allows you to deploy your  application faster it also delivers a  better user experience by improving data  consistency eliminating inconsistent  reads and helping to reduce  time-consuming bugs Google Cloud spanner  fast-track your applications path to  success